what happened in america on the 11th of
september 2001
changed the course of history
on my orders the united states military
has begun strikes
against al qaeda terrorist training
camps and military installations of the
taliban regime in afghanistan
britain stood shoulder to shoulder with
its great ally against the new threat of
international terrorism as you will
know from the announcement by president
bush military action against targets
inside afghanistan has begun
i can confirm that uk forces are engaged
in this action
in 2001 america supported by britain
invaded afghanistan to root out those
responsible
they toppled the taliban government who
were protecting osama bin laden and
sought to rid the country of al-qaeda
bin laden escaped to pakistan but by
2002 in less than a year in the country
america declared afghanistan free of
al-qaeda
but the strategic goal posts moved and
president bush called for the
reconstruction of the country
by 2002 the taliban was reorganizing
their leader mullah omar launching an
insurgency
and so followed years of bloody war
it was never going to be a military
solution in afghanistan there was always
going to have to be a political solution
so in many ways the troops were let down
by the politicians they did what was
asked of them they created the
environment in which the afghans had an
opportunity to build a better country
um i still think that opportunity was
there so the troops did what was asked
of them and you know they should be
proud of themselves and the sacrifices
they made
but political attention and military
efforts were diverted to iraq and by
2006 british troops deployed to helmand
province found themselves exposed
it was considered afghanistan's most
dangerous region by this point the
taliban were using improvised explosive
devices known as ieds
without enough air support ballistic
clothing and poorly armored vehicles
british soldiers suffered catastrophic
injury and loss of life
snatch land rovers became known as
mobile coffins i think a lot of effort
courage
lives
limbs were expended
for an outcome that is
in every way
short of what we intended it's very hard
to judge any of our sacrifices today
as worth it given that outcome
no one suffered more than afghan
civilians more than 47 000 have died in
the conflict since 2001.
and repatriation ceremonies to the uk
raised awareness of the cost back home
the public all too regularly lining the
streets of royal wood and basset to pay
their respects
457 british personnel died in total and
as the number of grieving families grew
support for the long war in afghanistan
began to wane
british service personnel also came home
with life-changing injuries amputees in
their hundreds
but it wasn't just the physical cost
seventeen percent of those in combat
suffered symptoms of post-traumatic
stress
at its peak 150 000 nato troops were in
afghanistan but when fighting ended in
2014
just 13 000 remained supporting afghan
national security forces go it on their
own
and as that support withdrew after 20
years of war
lost lives and lost limbs
the taliban took the country back
in just 10 days
sally lockwood sky news doha